Can you guys hear me? We're
on rock and roll. Hi Guys.
Welcome. Awesome. So as you can see,
we're here to talk about human
connection in the digital age. Uh,
thank you guys for taking
the time to be here. Um,
so I want to start by thanking you
all because, uh, being at Google,
I know that you could be getting
a massage for free lunch for free,
haircut, for free, a lot of other
things, but you're here with me and uh,
that makes me happy.
And so what I want to promise you before
we dig in today is that we're not just
going to talk about human connection.
Uh,
we're actually gonna talk about
how to connect in a digital age.
And so my goal is that you guys walk out
of here with tangible techniques that
you can use to connect with the people
you want and the people that you want to
know. How's that sound? Rock
and roll. So you guys void.
Again, this talk is going to be broken
up into three specific sections.
So stories about how was able to take
this deep yearning for connections,
curiosity about relationships.
Turn it into this business that has helped
100,000 people to give what we think
is the most meaningful gift in the world.
We're going to talk about stats had a
strong social ties and relationships
affect our brains and affect our bodies.
And we're going to talk
about tangible takeaways.
So how we can actually
communicate to connect.
So there's those three
components and before we start,
it's always nice to actually
establish what is human connection.
And my favorite definition
is this one by Bernay Brown.
I define connection is energy that exists
between people when they feel seen and
heard and valued, and when they can
give and receive without judgement.
And when they derive strength and
sustenance from the relationship,
a beautiful articulation of that
energy that exists between two people.
When we feel connected and at tribute,
we've actually broken
dot down even further.
So we've created a construct that can
allow people to evaluate the depth of
their relationships, that which they
have an abundance of. That's what's that,
which they're really seeking.
And we call that Avs.
So avs is a mutual
feeling of a appreciation,
mutual recognition of the other person.
Do you see that person?
Do you appreciate who they are?
Needs to exist for human connection?
Second,
vulnerability.
Can I be honest with this person?
Can I be truthful with this person?
Can I be fully myself with this person?
Vulnerability is the bridge to connection.
Next is support and support's a beautiful
thing and the way you think about it
in human connection as a natural
call to support and be supported.
And so these are the three components
that we can break down when human
connection truly exists and easy way
to evaluate your friendships as well as
those new relationships
that you're adding depth to.
That's our definition of human connection.
So we all know that human connection is
important to experience, to have fun,
to magnify joy.
But I also want to introduce you to why
we should really care about our social
ties are relationships.
And to do that,
I'm going to introduce you to a
guy named doctor Robert Waldinger.
So doctor Waldinger did the longest
study on happiness in our history as a 75
year longitudinal study of 750 people.
When they released this research,
he gave this famous Ted talk.
And also as I was perusing through
the results of that research,
there was one statement that
they literally highlighted
and bolded to emphasize
its importance.
And that statement was this.
The clearest message we got from this
study is that good relationships keep us
happier and healthier,
period.
Good relationships keep us
happier and healthier period.
So from this research,
we can assume that strong social ties
investing in our relationships is probably
the smartest investment we can
make in our overall happiness.
But it goes beyond just happiness. What
about our health? What about our brains?
What about our bodies?
So recent research also shows
people who have strong social ties.
The medical term to connotate
relationships have longer lives,
stronger immune systems,
literally higher levels of white
blood cells to fight off disease,
lower levels of stress and anxiety,
and they're less likely to dive into
bad habits like smoking or drinking and
alarming study.
I recently ran into said this,
having weak social ties is as harmful
to ongoing health as being an alcoholic
and twice as harmful as obesity.
So again,
when we have weak social ties, it's
not just a detriment to our happiness.
It's a detriment to our health
and our mental wellbeing.
So it's something that
we need to care about.
And so now I want to tell you guys a
little bit about how I got into this line
of work,
how I was able to study human connection,
start businesses that are bolstering
relationship and gratitude in the world.
And it started when I was 10 years old.
The first job I can remember is selling
these books in the back of a room from
my mom. My Mom's an eight time published
author. She talks about communication,
networking,
articulating the value of your ideas.
So this thread of communicating to connect
with something that was ingrained in
me at a very young age.
And so one of the common threads
through my childhood was sports.
It was how I connected playing
basketball, football, and Lacrosse.
Right before I graduated,
I was enlightened to the
power of adaptive athletics,
helping young people with disabilities
to unite with their peers through sports.
And that inspired me to
start dreams for kids, DC,
a community that brought kids together
to play all these incredible things you
see up here. Waterskiing outdoor
adventures, hockey, Lacrosse,
using sport as a facilitator
of human connection.
Then I got really interested in tech
and I started to look at bigger problems
affecting the dip, the people with
disabilities in their community.
And so we've built ability list,
an online platform that allows people
with disabilities to share the resources
they know, they know about
and that they need. So again,
building community with
an online platform.
So this passion for connection,
this curiosity about communication took
a step up to the next level when I was
27 years old and it all
started with a gift.
So my fiance Mickey is in the
back of the room right now. Um,
and on my 27th birthday she took me out
to dinner and Brooklyn where we live. Uh,
we come back to our apartment and always
remember that I swing the door open
thinking that we're going
to have a low key night.
And then there's a silence
and then three, two, one,
all these people jump out. She had
planned this incredible surprise parties.
So I'm hanging out with all of our
favorite people in the apartment.
Halfway through the Party,
Mickey jumps up on a chair and she yells,
everyone in the living row.
So everyone runs into the living room.
She sits me right in the back and she
had rented this projection screen so she
puts it up on the wall. I have no idea
what's going on and I would soon find out.
So Mickey had taken the time to reach out
to 25 of my closest friends and all my
family members.
She asked each one of them to submit
a one minute video telling me why they
loved me. Even telling you this, I
get goosebumps over my entire body.
So as I sat there in the back of the room,
these videos started to stream my best
friend in New York calling me his best
friend.
For the first time ever,
my brother telling me how grateful he
is that we're finally friends again.
My mom telling me how proud of me she is.
And that was about the moment that what
Alan Watts would call tears of wonder.
Joy started to flow.
Not even a cute little cry,
but like a big ugly, like massive
drops coming down. One of those cries.
And I did that for the next 20 minutes
straight because I remember when it
stopped, the first thought
I had in my head was, wow,
I just watched my eulogy at 27,
which is a much better time to
watch her eulogy in my opinion. Um,
so I needed a break and I walked over
to the next room and I just looked at
Mickey and I said, that was the best
gift I've ever received. And I said,
how'd you do it? And She just looks back
at me and she says, well, it was terrible.
And so she says,
again,
it was hundreds of emails to remind
people to submit their videos,
collecting files through Dropbox, drive,
text message. And last but not least,
editing everything together.
And I movie.
So it took her about 15 hours
and it was then in there,
I had this innate understanding
of the power of this gift.
And I realized the only reason more
people didn't get it was because of how
difficult it was to create.
So then in their tribute was born.
And so tribute is our website that
automates the process of building one of
these gratitude filled video montage
is it automates the process of inviting
your friends of collecting videos.
And we built the first web
based collaborative video
editor to easily put these
things together. And it started as
a simple mission to share that joy,
those tears of wonder joy that I felt
in the back of the room with the world.
And last two years have been really fun.
So over 50,000 tributes in 40
countries around the world. Yep.
That's Regis checking us out on the today
show. That was appearance number two,
which was very fun. Uh,
but most importantly,
what we're most excited about is that
we feel that we're deeply ingrained in
this digital intimacy movement is that
we are an mission to leverage the power
of video to spread gratitude and human
connection in the world is how can we
build technology that adds
significant value to our users,
offline relationships.
And we think that this is
not only something that we
are personally passionate
about,
but something that is incredibly relevant
right now because it's a society.
We are more connected than we have ever
been and we are quantifiably lonelier
than we have ever been.
At the same time,
in 1980 arp ran a study of
their entire membership,
the Association for Retired Persons in
1980 the number of people who identified
as lonely was 20% that's a lot.
They did that same study in 2010 and the
number had doubled to 40% 40% of their
entire membership identifying as
lonely at the same time when they're
identifying more connections and more
acquaintances than they were in 1980 1980.
So next and even more alarming study
talking about in 1985 the American
sociological review did a study and what
they found was that in 1985 the average
person had three confidence,
three people that they could confide in,
that they considered close friends.
When they redid that study in 2004 that
number dropped from a three to one close
confidant to one close friend.
And to put it in even more perspective
of the people that they serve,
I have the people that they surveyed,
25% said that they didn't have one
person that they could confide in.
25% are saying that they
essentially don't have one person,
they consider a close friend.
And that matters.
We just talked about what
happiness or excuse me,
what relationships do for our happiness,
what it does for our help for health.
When people don't feel they belong,
they'll do crazy things to fit in.
So this is a human connection crisis.
Is this something that matters?
Something that deserves to be looked into.
So what's the role of technology
here at Google as an entrepreneur,
as a designer, how can we think
about tech's role in this?
And when we first started seeing
social media exploded onto the scene,
there were a lot of surveys that
correlated loneliness and depression with
increased exposure to
social media networks.
More research coming out today
actually has conflicting reports,
whether it's actually lonely people,
depressed people who spend more time
on social media and on the Internet.
And so I want to move beyond that.
And when I focus on one thing
that the research does back up,
and that is that we get out of the
Internet, we get out of social media,
what we put into it.
Okay?
And the clearest example I can lay for
you guys is that if you're on Facebook,
if you're browsing your
friend's profiles passively,
if you're taking what we call
the one click actions at tribute,
if you're just liking a photo, if you're
sending one on your friend's birthday,
it's a trigger. That birthday message that
both of you know, it's like no thought,
no effort.
You are not adding to your social capital.
You're going to leave that
experience feeling more isolated.
But if you're going on to these platforms,
if you are composing messages,
if you are being thoughtful,
sending authentic birthday messages,
sharing the articles
that you're discovering,
then you are going to leave those
experiences more connected. So it be,
when we think about in our design ethos
is what are the human values of the
people that are using tribute as opposed
to the traditional KPIs of a tech
product, of vitality, of
interactions, of growth, of revenue.
How do we quantify the
values of our users?
And that's why we have metrics like t o j,
which literally tracks the
number of recipients who
cried tears of joy and guess
what that number is today?
80% 80% of those 50,000 reported
the recipient crying tears of joy,
quantifying the number of people who said,
I love you in their videos.
Quantifying the percentage of people who
feel more connected after giving their
tribute. So we moved from things like
more interaction to what does a meaningful
interaction quantified by our users.
Looking at ease and focusing
more on thoughtfulness.
What does a thoughtful interaction for
our user and looking at more connections
and number of invitees and number of
friends and actually understanding what is
a deep relationship look like and how
can we move towards those relationships.
And so if we understand that we need
to help people make these thoughtful,
thoughtful decisions for themselves,
that's the role of technology.
That's what we can do to
help people as technologists,
as designers is entrepreneurs.
And so I attribute,
we really believe in the
power of communication,
the power of communication
to help us connect.
And like I promised in
the beginning of the talk,
I really do want to help you guys walk
away from today with tangible techniques,
things that you can use in everyday
interactions with friends, family,
networking events,
everything you've got.
So the first thing we want to
talk about is sharing gratitude.
Sharing gratitude may seem like a simple
thing in theory, but as we talked about,
when we define connection,
appreciation is that first
cornerstone of meaningful connection.
And appreciation is powerful
for a few reasons. Number one,
it allows the recipient to see those
qualities themselves that they sometimes
may deny.
Second,
it reinforces those feelings
of appreciation and gratitude
that we have for that
other person.
So it's literally like a mini gratitude
meditation when you actually say and
articulate your gratitude out loud.
And third,
and most beautifully is when we
share a compliment with someone.
And recent research backs this up.
They're not only more likely
to reciprocate with us,
but they're more likely to give someone
a compliment in your local community.
So it creates this beautiful chain
reaction of gratitude every time we tell
someone why we appreciate them.
And so now I want to introduce you to
a few of our favorite sharing gratitude
techniques.
And so the first is not I love you.
The first is I love you because,
and one thing that we should understand
it is that it is not our articulation or
sentiment of affection that impacts the
recipient. So when I walk out the door,
it's not, I love you Mickey. That truly
impacts are it's, I love you Mickey,
because you inspire me and you
support me as much as anyone I know.
It's not saying thank you to your
coworker. It's saying, thank you.
I was going through a really tough
week and this really helped me out.
It's when we go beyond that simple
sentiment of affection that the recipient
truly feels the meaning,
the intention of what we want to express.
It's that simple transition of,
I love you too.
I love you because use that one word
and watch how it transforms the way that
you communicate. The next is the
idea, the power of the prompt.
I was just talking about the fluorine
in the front row and it's the idea that
sharing our gratitude can sometimes
bring on a little bit of anxiety.
We don't want to tell someone how they've
impacted our lives are that we love
them because we don't know
what they'll say back to us.
We don't know if they'll reciprocate.
We don't know if we'll make them
uncomfortable and when we don't know those
things, oftentimes we don't push
our boundaries. We just don't do it.
And so oftentimes we need these prompts.
We need to help people by giving them a
question that helps them to articulate
their appreciation for someone.
So the way that we do this on tribute
is every campaign we do is based around
prompt questions. So it's not what
do you love about Katia or sorry,
it's not send Katia a birthday message.
It is. What do you love about Katya?
It is what's your favorite
memory with Katia?
How has Katia impacted your life?
So prompt questions allow you to unify
the conversation for an individual.
It automatically plants an emotional
sentiment in someone's brain.
So if you ask someone a question now
they're already have this feeling as
opposed to giving someone an open slate
and saying, film of birthday video,
tell them you're grateful for them.
It's really when you provide that context
for creativity that people are more
comfortable and compelled sharing.
So the challenge here would be the next
time that you're at a birthday dinner or
the next time someone is taking off or
just basically landed a huge project,
the what we call a conversation catalyst.
Be the person who stops the dinner and
says, Hey, we're all here for Heather.
Let's go around the table and everyone's,
tell her what's your favorite thing about
Heather via conversation catalyst and
watch how that unites your group,
your community,
and how impactful that will be on the
person that you folks do you focus on.
Does that make sense?
Okay,
awesome.
So the next one is another simple one.
Uh,
and it's the idea of being nice first is
that so often we wait for permission to
share that kindness that we
feel the gratitude, we feel
the thanks that we feel.
And the way that I want to kind of ground
this in your memory banks is to think
about that saying that we all
heard a thousand times growing up.
So you tease a kid on the playground,
you're mom would see you,
she'd come over to you and she'd say,
if you don't have anything nice to say,
don't say it at all.
So watch this.
If you look at those two
don'ts and you get rid of them,
you know what it becomes. If you don't,
or if you have anything nice to say.
Say it all.
It's this simple idea that whenever
we have a kind feeling a compliment,
we feel thankful for someone.
There is no good reason to ever
keep that inside of your head.
Just think about any
time you've ever been,
you ever received a compliment and said,
gross
never happened.
So if you have anything nice to say,
say it all.
So next I want to move into our second
part of the communication techniques,
and that's something that we call
the art of meaningful conversation.
Before we move into this,
does anyone have any questions about
that first element of sharing gratitude,
articulating our gratitude
and appreciation?
Yeah.
We'll open up for questions
at the end as well.
So the art of meaningful conversation
is grounded in the idea that human
connection starts with communication.
So the art of meaningful conversation
is about overcoming anxiety.
It's about adding value in conversation.
It's about listening attentively.
It's about connecting and feeling
confident in any social interaction.
And we can think about it broken up this
way, fam. Finding your authentic voice,
asking better questions.
And the metamorphic to
step to translate presence.
So before we get into that,
I want to address something that is the
biggest deterrent and barrier to human
connection in my opinion.
And that is social anxiety and shyness.
And so again, I want to define
social anxiety in clear terms.
Social anxiety can be defined
as the fear of negative.
The social anxiety is the
fear of negative judgment.
And another thing that I want to establish
is that recent research shows that
about 60% of all people say that they
are dealing with some issues of social
anxiety or shyness.
It is not rare.
And when we were dealing with
social anxiety or shyness,
we have an aversion to social interaction
is going to keep us from dating the
people we want to date from meeting
the friends we want to be friends with,
from getting the job that we deserve.
And so again,
if social anxiety is simply the
fear of being negatively judged,
some people leap to the assumption that
we should just stop caring what people
think.
But that is not the path to connection.
That is an easy path to narcissism.
And sometimes the White House.
So we can start by finding our authentic
voice and the authentic voice is this
deep understanding of who we are,
what we care about and what we want.
And the reason that this is so important
is that if we don't know who we are,
what we stand for,
we will constantly revert
to seeking validation from
others is that we will need
other people to tell
us what is acceptable,
what is cool as opposed to being
driven by our own intuition,
morals,
values.
And there's a simple test that
you can use in any situation,
whether you're in a meeting at Google,
whether you're in a party,
whether you had Thanksgiving
dinner with your family.
Net simple test is this one question,
am I doing this because I want to be or
because I think people will like it or
think it looks cool and the clearest
example I can give you of this and we've
all been there, don't even lie that
you haven't is you're at a party,
your friends haven't showed up and then
you pull out your phone and you're just
looking at it doing absolutely nothing.
Like everyone just smiled
so we'd been there.
It's you don't want to just
do nothing on your phone.
You're doing that because you're worried
about the perception of other people
thinking you're weird
or whatever it might be.
And the easiest construct that you can
think about in these moments is am I
being driven by internal
motivation or external motivation,
internal versus external.
Why am I doing what I'm doing right now?
Always ask yourself and remind yourself
to revert back to that internal
motivation and we can all start.
Here's another challenge,
how to find your authentic voice starts
by articulating your answers to these
questions and too many of
them I hope that you do.
You have a feeling and
understanding of these,
but when you actually take
the time to answer them,
to put the words that
these questions deserve,
you'll go in to social
interactions with more power,
a higher understanding of yourself,
and it will translate to
greater presence and greater.
And one of the beautiful things I think
about when I look at questions like this
is that the answers will always change.
And that's okay.
That's a beautiful part of life.
The questions will remain the same,
but just the mere fact that these answers
will change is not an excuse for not
having an answer.
So meaningful conversation starts with
us in establishing that understanding of
self.
So the second is to ask better questions.
And one thing that we can establish when
we think about asking better questions
is a path to human connection or these
two things is that when we're asking
questions and listening attentively,
we will always leave a good
impression on our counterpart.
And beyond that we will
always make them feel valued.
So we are asking questions and listening.
You are always going to leave a positive
impression on the person that you're
speaking with.
On top of that,
questions are the most effective
path for learning and growth.
If we are learning,
if we are growing,
there is always fulfillment to be had
there. And as our pal Gandhi said,
when you talk, you are merely repeating
what you know. When you listen,
you may learn something new.
And again,
I love these constructs that
allow you to evaluate, um,
how you're being in any given moment.
And another question that you can think
about whatever you go into a meeting
before you go to your next conference,
ask yourself this one question.
What am I most excited to
learn about this person?
It's actually taking 60 seconds before
you hop on that call and just identifying
what am I most curious about?
When you establish a foundation of
curiosity to take him to any social
interaction,
you now have a virtuous path through
that entire interaction because of those
two things we established
before articulating our
curiosity will lead us into
virtuous connection in every interaction.
You can trust that.
Here's another one of those constructs.
The idea of being interested
over interesting and it
actually should be an equal
sign there.
It should say that if you are interested,
you are interesting and you will be
received well by other people. And again,
this incredible quote by Einstein,
I have no special talent.
I'm only passionately curious.
And the idea of going through
life to understand people,
to understand the world in my opinion,
is just one of the best ways to experience
life and something we can all aspire
towards.
And you can also help yourself by giving
a foundation of questions that I call
your go tos,
is that give yourself a leg up.
I've been talking about human connection
and relationships for so many years,
but at the end of the day I revert back
to the same questions because there was
a through line,
there was a theme to what I want to
understand about the people I meet.
So if you think about these questions,
you can trust yourself
to fall back to these,
these more virtuous paths of communication
and conversation in any given moment.
So think about what yours are.
Here's a few that I've always loved.
What are you most excited about?
What's most challenging right now?
Because when we talk about
challenge and struggle,
we opened up an opportunity to
support and to be supported.
What's your fee? What's your focus at
the moment? What's important right now?
What's the dream?
Identifying what people really want to do.
And you guys want to talk about
your dreams or your day job. Oh,
you guys work at Google.
So it was probably very cool.
About the same time
talking about our dreams.
What we really want is where
we can find that energy,
that passion and the stuff that
we really want to connect on.
What do you care about?
That's simple question to get
to what is important to people,
which is an incredible thing to
understand and get to know someone.
So the Max is probably the simplest step
of all these things that we're going to
talk about in the art of
meaningful conversation. Um,
and so the reason that we need this
is because presence is tantamount.
If we want to connect with people,
if we have a negative internal dialog,
if we're thinking about other things,
if I'm not right here to talk to
you and to look you in the eyes,
I'm not fully capable of articulating
myself. I can't listen to you fully.
And so presence is important.
And another thing to identify is that
our brains priority is not to connect our
brains.
Priority is to keep us safe.
And our brain is really good at telling
us all the things that are going to go
wrong.
Our brain is really good at taking us
into the meeting and telling us why this
person's not going to invest in us about
why this person is not going to like us.
They're not going to think I'm smart.
They're not going to think I'm pretty,
whatever it might be.
And so we need to remind our brain
what feeling good looks like.
We need to remind our brain
what we want to happen.
And so it's again,
this simple two step process that I
learned from a hypnotherapist in New York
City. I remember I walked into a
party, I met this guy and I said,
so what do you do?
And he's like,
well I'm a hypnotherapist and
I stopped them and I said,
I'm going to coronary you and
ask you a hundred questions.
Are you okay with that? And he was like,
yes. And so the first thing I asked is,
so what's the number one thing
that people try to get rid of?
And what do you guys think it is?
Smoking is the one everyone says,
that's what I said too, but it is
not smoking. He said self doubt.
Self doubt is a number one thing that
hypnotherapist are asked to cure.
And so then I went down this
line of questioning. I said,
so if you want to cure someone
of self doubt, what do you do?
And he said that the first step is
articulating the undesired state.
So putting words to this negative feeling
because then it has less control over
us. So it's again, before you go into
that meeting, it's actually saying,
what's going to go wrong?
How do I not want to feel those
things that we just talked about?
They're not going to think I'm smart.
They're not going to think I'm experienced
enough. We're not going to connect.
That's the undesired state of being.
And so this one little question in step
two can change everything and we'll take
you 15 seconds before you go
into any meaningful interaction.
How do I want to feel?
So before I stepped foot
in this room today, I ask
myself, how do I want to feel?
And I said, I want to be passionate. I
want to be myself. I want to feel loose,
so happy, passionate, loose HPL.
Now I have three things and whenever I
have any sort of doubt or anything that
takes me out of the moment,
I have these three desired states
of being and then I can tap into.
Right now I am here as Andrew
the way that I want to be.
I promise you that if you just ground
yourself in the metamorphic to step before
any important meeting,
it will transform your ability
to connect in that conversation.
Does that make sense? How
do I want to feel? Awesome.
Um, so we're about to close.
And before we do that,
I want to invite you guys into a
quick 62nd gratitude meditation.
So if you guys will just sit back
in your chairs, literally 60 seconds
and you can close your eyes,
you can open your eyes,
whatever you're most comfortable with.
So what I'd like you to do is
close your eyes if you'd like to.
And on the count of three,
we're going to take one big breath in one,
two,
three.
And now with your eyes closed,
just feel the sensation of
your breath as it goes in,
as it goes out.
And now I'd like you to think about
one person that you're grateful for
who is one person that's
had an impact on your life,
whether it's a mom, a dad, a
best friend, a significant other.
And just imagine that person
sitting right in front of you.
They're just looking right back at you.
And now I want you guys to remember,
I love you because,
and I want you to articulate
why you're grateful for them.
Why do you love them
and sit with that for a moment.
And on the count of three we're
going to open our eyes. Three,
two,
one.
I want you to take a look at
what's on the screen right now.
If you have anything nice to say,
say it all.
There is no reason to keep that kindness,
that gratitude that you feel
for that person who impacted
your life in your head,
that life is an incredible gift.
And to experience it with the people
we love isn't even greater gift.
So my last challenge and invitation to
you guys today as we close out is if
you'd like to at some point
today or right after this talk,
is texts that gratitude to this person.
See how it makes you see
how it makes them feel.
And hopefully you take this
into your life moving forward.
Thank you so much guys.
Okay.
Oh and we actually have one final thing.
So this is John Tributes,
community manager in the back. And so
in the vein of Google and free stuff,
we're going to give you guys a gift
card to create your first tribute on the
house. So there's probably about
70 of you guys that are here.
So I want to make sure that you guys get
to do this, whether it's for a birthday,
a wedding, a bar Mitzvah,
anything special coming up.
And for those of you that are online
watching this, if you tweet out,
we tribute and this talk will also reach
out to you with a free $19 gift card to
create your first DIY tribute.
Awesome.
If there's any questions, I think I'll
look at Katia to see how we do that. But,
um,
I love to field any questions about kind
of our research in the field or how we
got tributes started.
Whatever's on your mind.
So here,
there's a microphone right here.
Hi, great talk. Thank you. Um,
so before I came to Google,
I was a school counselor at
[inaudible] high school in the Bronx,
working with teenage girls.
And a lot of what you said kind of makes
me a little nervous for the younger
generations. Um, just because the style
of communication now is all they know.
And I think for a lot of us in this room
kind of got the best of both worlds.
So we have the ability to tap
into a lot of what you said. Um,
so I'm just curious if you've thought
at all about how to reach a younger
audience or, um, how to
kind of tackle those things.
Cause I found it really hard for
the girls to a be vulnerable. Um,
and that whole like self doubt thing,
they were,
they had no confidence in themselves.
Yeah. So just curious, like your tea,
I don't know,
ideas on targeting a younger
yeah. You know, so, so tributes,
target demographics and where we
focus on is on the 18 and above,
so where people kind of have a little
more emotional intelligence and are
capable of articulating these things.
So it's not where I've spent
most of my time at tribute,
but it was where I spent a great deal of
my time, uh, with dreams for kids. Um,
and I think that what we always lead
with when it comes to kids again,
are some of these values that we talked
about of leading with kindness before we
get to the communication aspect is
establishing that as a foundation of
interaction between people of
just being able to ask yourself,
is this a kind thing? And so, I mean,
when we were at dreams for kids, um,
we had this,
uh,
this thing that we embrace at any one of
our events because we were dealing with
a lot of kids with disabilities
is if you're ever unsure,
uh,
the,
the general consensus was that you just
go over and you ask and everyone just
seeks to understand.
And it was basically setting this
baseline of understanding between people
rather than making judgments and all
these other things. So I think, again,
you know, I don't do a lot
of work directly with kids,
but I think that establishing
that understanding of
seeking to understand your
counterpart and asking questions will
still be a virtuous path. Right. I mean,
when you think about
your time as a counselor,
what were the biggest challenges that
young girls who were finding with being
vulnerable?
Just that they were being attacked or
they weren't receiving that back to them
or,
yeah, a little bit of everything.
I think part of it was to, like,
they couldn't find an authentic voice
because everything was done for like,
uh, like on Instagram or it's for a
retweet or whatever. It was like the,
and they would give each other compliments
like on Instagram just to get it back
so that they could look at it and say,
I have 500 comments of how great I look.
You know,
so
I'm so happy you said that because it
really did just trigger something in me.
And, um, you know, my
reality is that I was,
I wasn't a great student throughout
high school and even college.
It's kind of like I went through and I,
I got grades,
but I was never fully present
their value, valued it. Um,
and no kind of guidance,
no speakers,
no counselors ever connected with me and
gave me insight or advice about how to
evaluate the world or how I want it to
live, my life that really connected.
And so when we talk about starting with
the art of meaningful conversation and
questions,
I think that that again is the best place
to start because if you empower young
people at a young age with a
foundational sense of self, who they are,
what's important to them, I
think that that's the most
important thing. And again,
you can give that to a
younger person and say,
here are some of the questions
that you can explore for yourself.
And when you can relate that directly
back to social anxiety and shyness and
some of those things that are much more
prevalent in high school and college,
then what happens is that you give
people a foundation to say before you can
feel confident in these situations.
Like the most important
thing is truly understanding,
trusting and loving yourself.
And so we can give that to young people.
I think that that's always where I would
start is not telling you when to do
anything, but providing them with a
construct to actually perform that kind of
introspection that leads to
virtuous interactions, connection,
connecting with the type
of people that we need to.
Yeah.
It's like almost trying
to get it proactive rather
than reactive because that
was like the, we were like trying to put
out fires almost, you know, and it was,
yeah,
it was hard to do at that point.
Yeah. My, my mom always says that the, uh,
the wisest teachers are the greatest
question askers and so that's what I
would emphasize. Cool. Thank you. Yeah,
absolutely.
Ah, this was a really welcome
interruption in the day. Uh,
I imagine the people in this room are
fairly self selecting group. Yeah.
As far as being concerned about
these kinds of issues. Uh,
can you talk about times where,
especially as somebody who's used
to being called intense. Yeah.
First meetings now, uh, for a lot
of the reasons you've discussed,
how do you navigate this when you're
meeting somebody who is unwilling to meet
you at that level and who
was uncomfortable with
these kinds of questions or
thinks that this is extremely unnatural?
Yeah, absolutely. Um, do you want to,
are you speaking in a business
context or social? Sure.
I think it applies to both. I think I'd
be curious. Yes, please. Let's start
with social.
And this is something that I've had
to come to grips with as well as, um,
you know, again, dealing with, you know,
my own anxieties and shyness with social
interaction and how I wanted to show up
in the world.
Uh,
one thing that I've become very clear
on later in life is that it is not our
responsibility to make
people feel comfortable.
It is our responsibility
to be honest to ourselves.
And this is within the construct
of, again, leading with kindness,
is that we cannot harm people.
So we need to lead with kindness,
but that ultimately it is not our
responsibility to make people comfortable.
It is our responsibility to be honest
with ourselves. And if we're exact,
if we're accepting some
of these principles about
asking questions and knowing
who we are, uh, and being fully
present, I think that, um, you know,
sometimes you are going to interact
with people who don't connect with you,
who are not on your frequency.
And I think that knowing that you showed
up in integrity in those moments as
yourself allows you to
not get hung up on them,
allows you to move forward. And
the reality is that, you know,
you only have limited time on this earth.
And so those people who aren't able to
meet you where you're at are oftentimes
not those people that you're
going to connect with. You know,
I'd say that again in a
professional context. Um, you know,
seeking to understand people is this
virtuous path where if people aren't going
to meet you all the way it, what's
your dream? And you're meeting them at,
you know, whether it's like
Penn station, whatever it is,
I think that there's a way that you
can start earlier on to get there.
And so again, I think that just because
someone can't meet you, they're like,
if you were to break down again,
and you talked about when
we were chatting right here,
like your perception of people
right off the bat. And, um,
I love the idea that your first
question is not your real question,
is that for a lot of people,
like they won't be able to
go there right off the bat.
So what is another question right after
that that you can go into? And again,
just allowing yourself to lead with
curiosity and what you want to know about
that person.
So if they're not willing to talk about
their dreams are what they care about,
um, what do you want to know about them
and why they're not willing to go there.
It's again, just giving yourself to that
process and seeing where that takes you,
I think is, I'm always going to be a
virtuous path. That makes sense. Yeah.
Thank you.
Cool.
Yeah,
it's touching again on the subject of,
of, you know, younger, a younger people,
children, you know, as they're
relatively new father. Um, and,
uh, you know, speaking from my own
experience on Facebook, you know, it's,
it's been my feeling pretty early on that,
you know,
a lot of people I know have exchanged a
few meaningful relationships with a lot
of meaningless ones. Yeah. And
a lot of really shallow ones.
So really kind of replaced depth with
breadth and we're not talking to each
other anymore where it
broadcasting. Yeah. Right.
And we're advertising so to speak.
And, uh, at least some of us do. And,
and it's certainly the
experience on Facebook, you
know, browsing Facebook, uh, uh,
it's,
it's an in this capable experience
of comparison and since you quoted,
but in a brown, I'm sure you
know her works and, you know,
comparison is the pathway to feeling less,
to feeling ashamed. Um, and I'm kind of,
and I feel that I myself, you know, I'm
fairly immune to, had, not completely,
at least I'm smart enough to avoid
exposing myself to too much of that.
Um, how, what, what are,
are there tangible things that we can do
to help children develop that immunity
to the inescapable world around us where
there'll be a lot of people that are
shallow or there'll be a lot of people
that will judge them using meaningless
tools like likes or, or
etc. And um, you know,
obviously developing self worth,
developing integrity,
these are principles I
can easily agree with.
But are there good tricks to
do that I guess is my question?
Absolutely. Well, expand on the,
the comparison a theme and then get
right back into how we can apply this to
young people and their browsing
and social media habits. Um,
one of my favorite concepts
with comparison, um,
is the idea that comparison
is the thief of joy.
And I just noticed this in any given
moment where I find myself comparing to a
competitor to someone else
who's finding success.
And in those moments where
you feel jealousy or anxious,
whatever it might be when
you're comparing. Um,
my first thought there and what I've
trained myself to do is to realize that
that comparison and that
malice or whatever it might be,
is nothing.
It has nothing to do with that person.
It's purely internal and it
says something about myself.
And so I think about the transformation
of comparing to celebrating,
which is what we want to do is that if
we cannot celebrate the successes of
other people,
it only says something about
us and our own insecurities.
So it's that shift from comparing to
celebrating. And if we cannot celebrate,
we can acknowledge that it's because of
our own insecurities and something to be
worked on because no one is perfect.
Um, and as it relates to young people,
I think again, rather than
telling them what to do, uh,
the best thing that we can do with
young people is to ask them why they are
doing things and to help them come
to their own realizations. And again,
how we do that.
It was with good questions and I'll
revert back to one that we talked about
earlier,
which is if you have a young person
who's posting on Instagram or is typing
these types of comments to simply
ask them like why are you doing that?
And to see kind of answer
that they actually have to
actually help them identify
those motivations for themselves to
see if it's something that they like.
And again, it's, you know,
we all remember our younger years and
it's like we are hardwired to rebel and so
when someone is telling us that
this is the way to do something,
we're going to be very resistant for
anyone to tell us what to do when we're
still formulating our own identity.
But when we can give people a construct
to do that meaningful introspection for
themself,
I think that that is probably the most
effective path to help them evaluate
those things.
So it's again,
it's just understanding why they're doing
those things and hopefully encouraging
designers and people at Google to be
thoughtful about how we are designing
products and what we're
defining as success.
Okay.
Thank you. Yeah, absolutely.
Anyone else?
One more or a few more.
Yeah, man, if you, uh, if you
emailed John attribute.co,
he'll be sure to send these out.
Thanks man.
Hi, I'm a huge fan. I'm doctor Rene
Brown. So you had me at Bernay Brown.
So I wanted to just ask if
you had any statistics on,
cause she talks a little bit about
this and several of her books,
but on how the expression of gratitude
is what actually gives you joy. Mm.
So do you have any, um, like are you,
is your company doing any type of
like studies on people that actually
participate in this and like their
levels of joy going up as a result of the
expression of gratitude? I would
just be interested to see that data.
Yeah. You know, so we partnered
with a nonprofit called, uh,
the grateful network. And so
again, they're doing a lot
of leading edge research,
uh, research along with the greater
good science center, which is, um,
a unit outside of UC Berkeley.
And they're doing some of the leading
edge research about the practice of
gratitude and what it's doing on the mine.
And so we have our internal metrics that
we talked about in terms of actually
quantifying,
uh,
expressions of love within these videos
of actually quantifying this act of
sharing gratitude, how that improves
your connectivity with your community.
And so right now again, these
50,000 people who've done it, um,
right now you're looking at 99%
of people who say that, you know,
the act of sharing this gratitude
for someone they cared about it,
made them feel more connected to their
community and tears of joy are now call
wonder joy. Um, so you can provide that.
But I'd say that those
are probably two of the,
like the networks that I check out
with more of the kind of leading edge
research.
So something that we're
kind of piggybacking off of
them to apply that into our
kind of like a in our design and
our development. Awesome. Thank you.
Thanks so much. So if you have
anything nice to say, say it all.
One of my favorite things as well as like
when I'm giving a talk and someone was
just like nodding cause like yeah,
she gets it.
You're nodding the whole time and
it's such a great thing to see that.
So thank you for that.
Yeah, that was awesome.
So who are you guys going
to give your tribute to?
Yes,
there you go. What? So that's
my fiance Mickey, by the way,
in the back of the room who gave me
the first tribute and inspired at all.
And now she's six months pregnant. We
just got back from the doctor. Okay.
Today
she's got a few now too.
And obviously I made her my wife.
So it works.
We actually just had a beautiful one.
Um,
we had a woman who proposed to her
girlfriend. How long was the video, John?
Yeah, an hour long. And you know,
just like some of the stories, again,
it's like I get goosebumps thinking
about it. So like this past week alone,
we had this woman who had an hour long
video to propose to her girlfriend.
We had another woman who just submitted
a testimonial and she was crying in her
testimonial video and she said,
I don't,
I gave this to my best friend in 55 years.
She was diagnosed with lung cancer five
years ago, and, uh, she didn't make it.
And,
um,
I did this video so that her
granddaughters would know who she was.
And the tribute ended up being an
hour and a half. And it's, again,
it's giving this gift of legacy and
gratitude and reminding people who someone
was. So, uh, if there's anyone in your
lives who's really had an impact, um,
we'd love to see you guys on the site.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Thanks guys.